n'a jamais été ensemble un espace aussi
petit j'aime pas du tout ce que je vois
mais croyait démarche
afrique africa iia le bus
tapas bouquet
bonjour la fine équipe est là je salue
je vous présente ma miss wic aisée car
hier françois de la chaîne m'habite week
et nico qui aujourd'hui sur notre guide
nous sommes dans les catacombes de paris
je m'appelle sam fisher la musique m'a
proposé de me rejoindre pour cette
énième exploration nocturne apparemment
ça va être un petit peu pas là mon
actuellement c'est une sorte de pièce en
fait une suite avec la mer et à la
malheureuse joueurs stones voilà ça hier
à la cathine l'été c'était le meilleur
endroit pour y jouer donc on va se
balader tomber sur des pièces comme ça
c'est très étroit très petit stress est
très lumineux aussi par endroits
justement voilà demain
j'ai pris ma vérité mais n'a pas pris sa
carte et les ja je fais une gamme de
housses j'ai oublié la carte sd dans mon
sac libre alès partie située à une
cartographie monde qu'est ce qui nous
arrive de ses pouces il se blesse on est
même revenue en arrière filé tout droit
et d'aller dans une petite chatte il est
ce que je dois te voler une anecdote que
tu vas me dire et autorise les chats
tiers ce sont en fait des petits conduit
creusée par des passionnés comme nous
pour aller d'abord un point b plus
rapidement c'est ça exactement à ce
qu'on fait à l'inspection de carrière
c'est un organisme créé par lui 16 en
fait qui avait pour but à la base de
consolider ses dires la passe il faut
savoir que ici dont convenait creuser
pour prendre de la pierre et construire
les bâtiments au dessus et il avait une
règle c'est elle et ses 50% dans la
pierre pour pas que ces fonds sauf sauf
purement légal ils ont commencé à vue
sont durs on s'en bat les couilles
on va prendre plus de bière puis 16
délice à l'apparent a créé l'inspection
de carrière et depuis plusieurs siècles
ces mecs leur rôle c'est de faire en
sorte que ces carrières reste solide
l'inspection elle va [ __ ] des
parpaings partout injecter du béton pour
bloquer tout sauf que les kadhafi là bas
ils ont envie de continuer à rigoler
on fait les dents la terre creuse eux
mêmes dans la roche dans la terre des
boyaux amis vont un peu pour accéder à
d'autres passages de dakar est donc voir
brad et on va leur dire merci du couple
soit l'argent en vendant tenté pas mal
on va regarder c'est vraiment effrayant
encore rien des mois ça normalement
droit d'entamer dès que je filme un
couleur vous n'êtes pas dangereux serait
dans un thé d'un jeu un jeu d'horreur
genre scpt à l'ancienne je vends mon
vieux oh [ __ ] ses droits regardez les
amis juste ici on dirait que le mur a
été cassé à la pioche vous permettre
d'avoir être finalement raccourci est ce
qu actuellement on est serein quand un
saut de suite franchement baby tweak
aventuriers c'est bizarre de passer d'un
mur nickel un mur un peu en lambeaux on
dirait qu'ils ont reflué de la roche
pour nous empêcher de passer c'est
bizarre donc là tellement ils sont
transversales allen avenue de choisy
donc la vienne choisi juste au dessus de
moi actuellement c'est très bien
vachement ce permis de laisser crever
aux plafonds différents gauche il a crû
de mes qualités l'épousé non monsieur
non je pense juste il ya peut-être td
assurance focus et avec les nappes
phréatiques tout on n'est jamais mais
j'attends des pistes en débat c'est
qu'il faut savoir en fait ça s'est
réellement que je n'ai pas dit c'est que
il ya un autre étage plus bas que nous
mais qui lui est complètement inondé il
ya de l'eau partout
une sorte de piscine municipale à
gratuite avait très peu traité en fin
mai que le timing plus de chance je vais
de verrues allait municipal qu ici je
suis ici un peu plus d'auteurs ça fait
du bien on peut se lever en et bien je
peux le maman bon après je permets de 20
mais je peux lever la main comme ça fait
du bruit derrière avenue dit avis bon à
la grosse ambiance intense et matin je
crois que c'est perdu
non non non c'était pas perdu si ce père
je le tue ça j'ai encore plus peur du
bon ok on arrive à un endroit où là ça
commence vraiment et de l'acaata qu'on
s'efforce bcr dans les bien content si
je fais ça ma tête touche le plafond
c'est intéressant on a encore du jus du
bois ici de dates et de poutres servi à
consolider à l'époque merci pour
l'anecdote c'est comment cette fois y'a
quoi là bas rien
et il ya de la pierre quoi mais non
c'est un joli sac je sais pas si ce qui
est le plus impressionnant le cul des
cas où le cas pour vous puissiez bien
vous rendre compte de la profondeur à
laquelle on est ici il ya un trou qui
avait directement à une plaque d vous
qui à la surface bolat informé que
j'allume ma langue de mes sam fisher oui
c'est juste
ouf comme ses pairs dont les amis on a
un objectif c'est l'objectif cabinet de
minéral le relais minéralogie merci à
tous
en fait un cabinet dans lequel on peut
trouver les différentes roches qu'on
peut trouver au sein des catacombes
voilà les mecs qui les a compilé une
sorte de la collection de roche
donc j'ai hâte de voir ça est en fait
une victime a expliqué que c'est pour ça
qu'ils seront dans l'oeuf à cusset qui
te raconte aussi beaucoup d'anecdotes
d'histoires il m'a expliqué qu'en fait
le cabinet avaient été condamnés et
grâce à une fameuse chatière donc car il
n'y avait qu'un passionné à à fait les
moyens de nouveau un passage qui dispose
pour aller dans ce cabinet donc j'ai
hâte de voir des donc du coup ça est un
tout petit passage très fin et mais mes
racines de grosses trop forts vont
peut-être me rattraper par une petite
marque ça ça indique qu'il ya un mec est
venu renforcer la structure en 1800 le
mec c'est peut-être mon arrière arrière
grand père ou alors c'est pas du tout
avec deux familles toit était boulanger
avait comme ça impressionnant dès que
j'arrête un peu de les suivre
je me fais caca dessus quand on est un
peu dure a nommé ouvrir les voies déjà
plus ça va tellement vite à se perdre
c'est ouf ça résonne un polar voilà
c'est tout se voit les ait d'autres
babioles csa a trouvé la grande salle
allende
trop cool on va découvrir ensemble
attention il ya même un petit zoom et ça
ça a été ça ça a été ça a été carrément
installé par les mecs et donc on avance
on se tape des eaux d'accord
petite marche on arrive à laitages
aubade en eau j'aime pas du tout aux
gemmes pas du tout ce que je vois un mec
si j'ai des beaux mecs givet j'entends
encore les autres donc je suis un peu
rassuré mais il ya des marchands [ __ ]
j'en laisse je me casse tellement france
dont on a tous à la paillade et marché
des jours où on va plutôt faire voir aux
chiens c'est hyper grand ici en fait
alors mais tu trouves moyens mais qui
est tombé la wii vient des couvertures
il était quand même très clair ici est
ce qu'il ya des gens qui amènent genre
c'est des amplis est qui et qui font des
concerts tu vois pas ce qui s'y est
franchement tu peux accueillir macho et
ben voila c'était la grande salle des
amis voilà c'est ça dans mes bras c'est
quoi cette porte donne car la salle est
verrouillé oui l'ancienne ouais c'est
des grenailles regardez moi ça c'est
vrai que c'était peut-être un bunker
donc mamie twink alias sherlock holmes à
élucider le mystère
en fait quand on était en bas où j'étais
en bas des marches là bas j'étais en
train de mener tout seul
en fait c'est tout ça c'est un abri anti
aérien qui a été construit il ya très
très longtemps est en fait la porte en
métal que vous avez vu un petit peu plus
haut il y avait d'autres portes comme ça
et en fait c'est une ancienne poste où
elle avait une attaque les gens venaient
se réfugier ici dans l' abri antiaérien
donc des emplois de la poste et gens qui
étaient dans le magasin ils venaient ici
quoi est il était en ambiance posée
tamiser le temps que l'attaqué se
finisse c'est plutôt un bon plan
finalement d'être postiers au moment des
guerres rendez compte ce qu'on est en
train de vivre
toute ma vie j'ai entendu parler de ces
[ __ ] de catacombes j'ai jamais pu me
rendre et aujourd'hui j'ai la chance
d'avoir des bottes qui ont l'habitude de
faire de l'urbex et qui m'emmène avec
eux c'est juste dingue
le fait jamais cette blague soupire
notre copine et vous perdre tout court
allez c'est parti pour la chatière donc
le cabinet n'entend pas tout à l'heure
où il ya plein de rouge qui sont exposés
n'est pas sur la carte mais nico de
mémoire saurait le retrouver à peu près
bien trouver la sortie je vais vous
avouer moi ça me va sam est incroyable
me convient de trouver le cabinet
minéraux jamais minéralogiques merci je
t'aime mais calmez vous avez vu en train
de fumer tue pas un truc très très fort
dé savoie je loupe
donc je vais avancer et on va découvrir
le cabinet avant florian mais regardez
pas ou faut passer mais qu'est ce qui se
passe dans cette vidéo ça prend une
tournure inattendue donc c'est ça une
chatière voilà quand les gens creusent
ça ressemble à ça j'ai un peu le flic
mais je vais faire pour vous un flou
rire le moment dont tu rêvais temps est
arrivé on va me voir en pls texte en
moins parce que là c'est la vraie
aventure j'ai commencé la soirée dans le
métro métro qui sait qu'il veut non
seulement sa trempe comme ça mais quand
tu es dans la chatte iraqiya m ou qui
passent mais non tu engages rien à les
autres gares aux quais c'est le départ
de florian alias mam et wink aux
chaussures qu'ils font rêver les plus
grands ça fait rien ça se concentrer un
petit peu je sais me lire les saintes
avait comme une sensation bizarre donc
nico je veux bien plus en jambes a les
couilles jean michel joseph totalement
mettez-vous de coutume ou les amis c'est
l'heure pour moi d'y aller d'aller dans
le trou du démon avec ma petite à
claustrophobie ça va être chaud mais
vas-y allégé l'esprit bombe à ces peurs
ggn mon gars all about uc vraiment en
train de me chie dessus mais
heureusement que ton doux visage me
console fournis
enfin je suis le salut qu'à la lampe
torche a eu trop d'hommes
en fait franchement florin ça va ça va
je dirais pas que je resterai là
longtemps et j'avais juste pour elle
visitera ces avoirs vont jamais trop
c'est le chrono du métro [ __ ] métro
arrive à bien métro qui paraît plus ça
fait des vibrations ça c'est vrai [ __ ]
ça vibre ouest en plus je le dis juste
avant que juste avant le film et on a
tourné et c'est une victoire
merci le prêt peut dire c'est cool et
donc ont atterri ici on peut tourner et
on atterrit du coup au cabinet mines et
ça commence par une table basse à ses
vieilles si on a une sorte de rite
vaudou qui permet d'invoquer une sorte
de satan finale et là on a ici les
échantillons de roches numéro x 21 11 10
donc ce sont dans des sortes de bougies
donc finalement ça a été remplacé
totalement et les bougies par contre
elle coïncide parfaitement avec
l'invocation de satan je pense vraiment
qu ici on a tenté un truc pas créé assez
chaud il y en a un
de ce côté-ci échantillon des bancs de
terre depuis la surface du sol jusqu'aux
bancs de proches donc est donc sûre sur
chaque marche de l'escalier y avait un
type de pierre ouais c'était une sorte
de nid musée c'est un des inspecteurs
des carrières qui a fait ça pour délirer
alors c'était saison cliff et s'assoit
avant il y avait des pires qu'à la place
des raisons toutes les allées ont toutes
été volé ouais ouais y'a des chances
c'est bête de voler sa femme ok les
habitants ne repartais dit si on reprend
la chatière et on va se diriger vers le
cabinet des sculptures la salle des
sculptures parle qu'on s'y colle un
comme on dit dans le milieu
donc là du coup on prend une position
inverse de tout à l'heure pour bien
passer dans un trou et là tu te mettes
tout droit et enroule un métro mais mec
j'ai trop tatillon ce poids dès que je
passe j'en ai trois nous sommes en
immersion totale
saric bah moi ça on n'a jamais vu dans
les conditions aussi terrible de
recherche je suis le tac a dit qu'il
veut un peu mieux si cela va être
compliqué
[Rires]
ambiance tamisée jamais trop aimé mais
c'est quoi ce délire avec le métro le
mec il le sait quoi obliger le cap voilà
le coeur vite on accélère on zappe la
station châtelet les halles lui a pas
vraiment fait gaffe ya de l'eau qui est
tombée sur tension mais non c'est juste
que tu sues le stress est totale bonjour
je suis florian g d or et des omoplates
et sommes un peu d'humour un peu de
vannes pour détendre l'atmosphère
chatière level 2 c'est celle dont je
vous ai parlé on ne sait pas où elle
mène un envie de savoir ce qui au bout
les gars il faudrait juste pas que sur
le couloir
quoi qu'on trouve en faisant hockey les
amis florian m'a devancé il est parti
sans dire un mot
il se sent chauds comme la base royal à
l'eau qui tombe regarder je vais surtout
faire attention à la cam des amis a
jamais été ensemble ça se passe aussi
petit j'ai employé sur le bret j'ai
compris ça marche bien ça ça tu kiffes
mon boulot françois je suis en gros plan
le coquin c'est physique cette mère en
fait son bras gauche la porte et le
porter la cape ça fait du bien aux bras
la galère pas trop si et là je suis quoi
je me retourne ouais tel un process ok
on arrivait version l'ami qu'est ce
qu'on a là bas du coup bah on va les
voir on n'a pas repris la chatière
convient de prendre ça qui était tout
petit je suis avec les gars et on va
faire du binôme yamam et wink et
françois c'est ça tu voyais leur côté
nous on va aller d'une autre mais nous
on va aller là-bas avec des cartes
[ __ ] c'est ça les avants on va voir ce
que ça s'arrête jamais ces interminables
rien à l'hérésie on avance a tenté
quelques zooms on peut voir non il ya un
trou là il ya un couloir qui passent là
en fait perdre et si je pense que ma
meeting et ou si on va là-bas
logiquement on peut les retrouver mes
oies façon ça à mon avis à moi c'est
bizarre tu as vu on voit une grosse
plaque de béton là bas au bout d une
énorme plaque de béton qui a l'air de
s'enfoncer dans ce conduit quoi on va
pas aller là-bas elle d'aimer tour il ya
des bruits je te jure y ait un bruit de
genre des bouts de bois qui affecteront
skc d'ici là on entend la voix on va
retomber sur mamier
mais c'est tellement simple de rabais oh
tu nous a rejoints on est au carrefour
on les voit la balle on est au carrefour
là bas il ya un florian et françois en
fait je rejoins tous rejoindre mais
parce que moi ça ce roulement sans
choisir c'est vrai ouais mais non oui
c'est ça c'était toi
[ __ ] géographe peur oh [ __ ] je lui
ai dit j'entends une chaise possédée par
un démon de la bonne nouvelle c'est
qu'on a retrouvé nos poteaux dont le
guide et la mauvaise nouvelle c'est
qu'on a pris une chatière pour rien on
en train de revenir au point de départ à
une icône nous dit que c'est hyper drôle
de le faire en marchant très vite en
fait il ya des gens qui va de la musique
à fond qui s'amusait à courir dans les
catacombes voilà il a d'autres qui
veulent juste inviter un pote et jouer à
l'heure tourne mais voilà
[Musique]
je suis conne et sévère hahahaha ça va
ça va c'est ce qu'a qui m'a tuer est la
faute la tête là moi je vois la salle
des sculptures la ben c'est la direction
on va faire peut-être la salsa en
passant est une taverne aussi à vous
amis nous sommes à mi chemin on vient de
tomber sur un puits j'ai vraiment pas
être tombé dedans regardez comme c'est
profond et en ballots et pas dégueu en
fait un ok les a mis là on arrive dans
la salle car c'est une salle qui précède
la salle des sculptures hockey nico a
pris un peu d'avancé les devants je
pensais pas qu'on ait vanté pendant de
si montrent en quoi ils mettaient seront
remarquables génique et le panneau
l'aide c'est pas grave ça me fischer est
là ok on arrivé voilà au [ __ ]
qu'est-ce qu'on avait ici c'est une
salle finalement forme circulaire très
sympa le petit pull jaune qui tient les
graviers plus long avec des pierres
pourri qui tient un mur comme ça l'a
marqué sécu à refaire ma gueule un
d'accord on est vraiment dans une grande
salle actuellement d'accord on dirait
vraiment d'étincelles temps un petite
crêpe party et cette salle qui a tué une
anecdote de plus alors ici en ce trou
dans l'un des lieux les plus anciens des
catacombes faut savoir que cette salle
c'était une carrière déjà au moyen âge
d'accord donc il est encore beaucoup
plus vieille que tous les autres
galeries qu'on a visités sa chacra de 7
kg et parviennent et escaladez diplomate
alors ça ça leur a été fait par les gens
qui viennent n'hésitez pas du tout cette
salle c'est une carrière du moyen-âge
donc je sais pas du 16e xvème siècle en
guerre au moyen âge il venait déjà
récupéré des pierres s'étaient des pires
de bien meilleure qualité que les
carrières alerte que dehors il pleuvait
il y avait le soleil il avait en
revanche ça abîme et la roche les
dominos range de meilleure qualité
donc ça fait des siècles et des siècles
que cette carrière existe elle a été
consolidée en 1793 juste après la
révolution française pour l'anecdote est
effectivement dans les années 2000 ils
ont créé un squat donc il
ils ont transformé ces la r&d valduc ou
en soit mais ça vous arrive bien tard il
était accusé à tort eh bien merci pour
ces anecdotes dont cheikh florian n'a
pas tout citer personne du coup la
prochaine c'est la saturn ou celle des
sculptures en fait il ya deux trucs
coller les deux prochaines salle ce sont
la taverne à la salle et sculptures sont
de celles qui sont collés à on est passé
devant la taverne méga d'accord donc en
fait on a un mur et ya juste un trou
dans le mur à un moment donné c'est
vraiment regarder la taverne
voilà on mène on a une mini table basse
on est ensemble et l'ambiance je faisais
tamiser la première salle qu'on a trouvé
ça faisait plus terne que sa gelée a
promis un excellent salon avait
maintenant une table et des bancs des
amis nous arrivons à la salle des
sculptures est sûre chez moi regarder on
a vraiment des piliers comme ça donc
savons que ça va être vraiment été fait
par des cathos fils ils mettent des tas
de pierres comme ça pour maintenir la
structure en place pour pas que tout
s'effondre et pour que des gens comme
nous puissent finalement admirer les
sculptures qu'il ya dans la pièce d'à
côté
ok on y est à séoul et sculpteur au
c'est beau ça et ça fait petit smiley
dans les murs c'est bon ça un petit
nounours mignon et ses enfants c'est la
seule mine young gods est oblique t à
des bijoux aux dames et là bas qu'est ce
qu'on a de très mignon villa au barça
c'est bien ça ça c'est mignon ça tient
aux ailes bien ça ici on a une petite
tête de mort elle est vraiment belle
pour le coup on attend on a cru qu'un
truc était une sculpture grenouille mais
en fait j'ai une vraie grenoble mardi 6
en ligne à ses jeux etc mais non
attention évènement groupe lancera début
si tu es sûr que ses membres aient
l'arrière par an tous les yeux 2012 mais
après elle est bien mieux mais je sais
pas si c'était chez pas c'est vrai qu'on
nous a franchement un visage dans la
pierre on a ici un crâne
ouais bon ça surement faux crâne non un
emploi
ni malin rappaz [ __ ] un chat hier un
crâne ici ok quoi d'autre what the fuck
quoi mais c'est quoi ça mais c'est trop
ou fnac
ça fait des années mais c'est trop bien
fait c'est trop bien fait waouh mosaïque
level 2 c'était l'objectif principal et
ça valait le coup puisque c'est la merde
ça c'est la galerie d'art assez ouf je
trouve ça vous de voir que des gens
viennent ici et prennent le temps de
faire des petites sculptures qu'ils
embellissent le lieu en fait c'est
dingue
après j'aurais bien aimé sculpter un
petit truc mais vu que je suis aussi
fort en sculpture camp des saints on va
éviter quoi ça parce que j'avoue
complexe et les amis sûrement vous êtes
très triste parce qu'on est sur le
chemin du retour je sais qu'ils me la
montrer pour me rendais bien compte du
truc à quel point ces gros c'était une
belle vidéo les amis je suis très
content on a refait son excellente
nouvelle échelle
on a retrouvé la sortie on y va c'est la
déroute et c'est la dernière
elle est en fait la monte plus
impressionnante qu'elle a descendu mais
peut-être parce que en fait je me suis
mis en première ligne et du coup
forcément tous jusque là encore la
dernière plaque
je suis à la fois juste réussir d'un
élément comme ils sont dégueulasses
c'était bien
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est la fin de cette exonération
nocturne comme dirait florian dans les
catacombes de paris
c'était bien c'est devant donc où
s'arrêteront le merci youtube est devenu
berger et ben merci à wigan avoir habité
n'hésitez pas à aller voir la chaîne de
ces deux là ça s'appelle une amie tweak
bien sûr nico le guide jousset docile
chaîne youtube mobile d'apple heureux
hit the road et hier sur nos des
sketches aux offres paniquez pas paniqué
par danic avait juste à cliquer souvient
de la session pour les valeurs chaîne
c'est vraiment du bon contenu que ce
soit nico qui monte on à tour eiffel à
moins du sne le grand barbare ou même et
wind qui fait plein d'exploration
nocturne comme ce qu'on vient de faire
ce soit parfois même un petit peu plus
frissonnant avec les petites touches de
hoya peut-être un fort taux longs s'est
pas dans la maison mais justement
d'ailleurs les amis aujourd'hui c'était
une exploration vraiment côté histoire
et aventure mais si vous voulez voir
celui ci dans un lieu un peu plus
flippant un lieu peut être d'y monter le
nez de boeuf des commentaires est la
tête des crêpes des gravats c'est à
françois qui a cadré quelques plans pour
même ma vidéo à moi qui amènerait tous
les plans pour les deux hommes a eu ce
week end à l'aller gallas et à tous un
mec ce bijou à vous n'hésitez pas et
mezzo ça vous a plu et on se retrouve à
une prochaine
[Musique]
i